Aloha from Waikiki I am currently
recording on a makeshift standing desk
attached to the top of a fridge in a
microwave on the Hawaiian island of Oahu
now there's an active volcano not very
far away and the world's loudest bin man
outside as well so if you hear some
explosions do not fret it will just be
the end of the world or the bins being
collected now before I forget the modern
wisdom youtube channel is live very
happy to say that we've nearly hit 1
million watch minutes within the space
of the first month it's absolutely crazy
the response to the love island podcast
has been insane shout out to the British
press for both promoting and
misrepresenting what I said but all
exposures got exposure as far as I'm
concerned the love island podcast it's
still not available on audio only so if
you want to check that out you're gonna
have to head to the YouTube channel
please hit subscribe as it would make me
very happy coming up soon I have the
long-awaited sequel to Jordan Wallace
Paul warrior and Tim Briggs from Reebok
CrossFit Tyneside we dominate nutrition
and warrior programming plus the world's
only happy ologist
positive psychology expert Susanna
Hallinan will be dropping in to talk
about happiness and her new book but
first onto this week's guest Warren Kass
is an author public speaker businessman
entrepreneur and a specialist in
influence and personal brand development
I've wanted to get on the podcast for
well over a year now from before I even
started I knew that I wanted to get him
on I picked up his book influence which
will be linked in the show notes below
along with all of the partner companion
stuff that he gives away for free on his
website
I think to one degree or another
everybody requires influence in their
lives they need to be able to control
how their personal brand comes across
and they need to be able to communicate
effectively now this isn't just about
being a go-getter chasing after the next
big job or whatever it might be this
could just be being a better partner
being a better parent being a better
whatever you need to be able to
communicate effectively you need to be
able to control how your personal brand
is projected out into the world what is
the sort of example that you are setting
what are the sort of things that other
people professionally personally say
about you when you're not around what is
the kind of influence that you are
having on your circles now Warren takes
us through a step-by-step personal brand
and influence MOT if you are someone who
wants to improve their ability to
communicate online or in person their
access to networks their ability to
influence others in a positive way if
you've always wanted to understand how
neuro-linguistic programming works even
if you've always wanted to know what
people's eyes looking in different
directions during a conversation means
we go through it all so get your pen and
paper up make sure that you ready here
we go
Warren casts on influence
[Music]
mr. Warren cast welcome to modern wisdom
thank you for having me Chris great to
be here how are you today
bloody marvelous you know I've had a
really really busy month I've got a
couple of days in the office which just
you know catching up time so yeah really
good thank you fantastic for a little
bit of time to reset yeah you need it
every now and then don't you yeah for
sure for sure it's been a it's been a
difficulty in getting hold of you but I
think that's that's a test testament to
how much you're in demand at the moment
speaking about the topics that you do
yeah it's very flattering them but you
know obviously waited to talk about
influence today and as somebody like
yourself who builds a personal brand you
know the bigger the brand gets the more
in demand you get and it's all good yeah
it becomes a bit circular doesn't it so
you've touched on the word of the day
there can you can you define what
influencer means to you yeah in very
very simple terms it's a broad topic but
in very simple terms for me it's about
effecting an outcome without having to
force it without having to force it also
means of course without having to
manipulate you know we we live in
elsewhere we're bombarded every single
day with so many messages and some of it
is misinformation and some of it's
manipulation but come on coming back to
my definition of influence influence is
really when you can uh you can forward
an idea or agenda without having to
force it where people come along because
they want to have been inspired to
that's that's how I like to define
influence I understand so I I picked up
influenced the book round about a year
ago and was on a flight out to America
to get something I could read on the way
out and immediately stood out to me
exactly as you said we increasingly now
in the modern world almost everybody to
one degree or another is building a
personal brand you know the advent of
social media means that everyone treats
their Instagram or Twitter account to
varying degrees of professionality like
a traditional advertising medium its
advertising for themselves and whatever
the goal is can change but I do think
that the the hype to a degree about
someone's own life gets proliferated by
them and upon reading it there was
a few bits which the event managers who
work for my company will hate hearing
over her over the Airways as I want you
up about it in the office sometimes but
serendipity is not a strategy for me
just sits it completely chopped the Me's
so many of the fortunate situations that
you get into and you can sometimes kid
yourself have come about due to some
preparedness that you deep down know
that you didn't do or some some
connection which was done by pure chance
the serendipity is not the strategy can
be should be written on the wall at some
points I think it it reminds me that we
need to be prepared and that we we need
to cover all of the the potential
avenues moving forward as we try to
create a personal brand so can you can
you tell us why you wrote the book yeah
I'll start by apologizing to your
colleagues there with your the Warren
Cass rhetoric gets pushed hard in the
Voodoo events office I'm afraid and do
you know what the serendipity has been
really really kind to me as I can't
complain at all but I've always had the
best results when I've done things on
purpose Don and with purpose I might say
so yeah I totally I totally agree and
what did I write the book well well
first of all I've been speaking on the
subject for well over a decade and I
wrote the book initially because I had
to publishers come to me say would you
write a book and I thought okay I've
always avoided this in the past because
I've got a you know a big listener to
podcast I subscribed to yours amongst
others and and knowledge you know is a
really important thing I think every
day's a school day so it's important to
continuously learn but I do think about
most business books is that they're
typically written by academics who
decide to give too many examples where
one or two would have done and I I
believe also most business books can be
summarized in you know a few pages
rather
and necessarily needed to take
everything on and I was really trying to
think hard about what am I going to add
value to this topic in a book format
bearing in mind there are some classic
books on this subject out there and I
mean for example you know in our
pre-chat you were talking about Dale
Carnegie how to win friends and
influence people probably the oldest and
biggest selling book on that topic it
was written in nineteen in the 1930s you
know you've got their psychology of
persuasion by child Eenie a brilliant
book written in the 1980s and he has
done some work since there but there was
a gap you know and what's happened is
we've had this explosion of population
of Technology since then and it's
fundamentally changed everything that we
do it's changed the way we communicate
the change way we access products and
services it's changed way we consume and
so the world has changed and we you know
for me it was a it was the thing I've
been evangelizing on stage about and I
thought you know what this is the angle
I'm going to take this is this is the
way I'm going to write the book those
are those things up to speed so to speak
absolutely proved to tried-and-tested
concepts but actually I make them
relatable to a whole new generation of
applicable to the changed world as well
I think definitely when you if you read
David Allen's getting things done it it
almost becomes laborious to convert so
he talks about like using filer faxes
and pages and you know like in trays and
out trays and stuff like that and you
think that I've actually got to do a
fair bit of the work this self-help book
requires me to do quite a lot of
self-help to get the book to work for me
because it's so behind the times with
what it would be it would be an app now
it would be a it would be a integration
like Evernote or something like that it
would be productivity tools and all that
sort of stuff and yeah you you're very
right I think as the rate of change
speeds up in the world the body of
knowledge around core concepts needs to
keep up
hundred percent or at least its
application yeah absolutely I agree so
can you talk about why influence is
important but does everybody have it
knowingly unknowingly
yeah vast majority of us have it and
should be aware of it if we if we want
things to happen in our lives you know
that's the simple fact of it and I often
start my talks with with you know
defining the fact that we're all
influenced every single day from the
moment we get up in the morning our
partners expression on the mood they're
in can dictate our day the
microexpression of somebody on your
commute to work whether it's a tube
train or car can dictate your mood for
the day it's been absolutely proven that
because we're such empathetic creatures
if we witness an act of kindness for the
t-mac hours they follow we are more kind
you know so we are sponges and we absorb
and that's just the human interactions
when you start factoring marketing
messaging and media you've got a whole
different layer of influence there -
yeah so the the bid I maintain is that
then if you understand how you're
received when you talk when you
communicate if you understand how that
comes across to others you've got a
better chance of being more effective in
that communication if you understand how
you you receive information and how
other people influence you you've got a
a better chance of having better
responses to that influence you know so
ultimately if you're an ambitious person
you want to evolve your career or even
if you just want to improve your
relationship with your wife husband
children colleagues friends
understanding influence is is in your
best interest so it's giving you some
perspective of what you're receiving in
what you're sending to a degree yeah and
you know all communication really should
start with an awareness of of how it's
being said what's being said because we
communicate on so many different levels
family so just in just increasing your
awareness will make you more effective
straightaway well
do you tend to start with people if you
were to do a an influence overhaul if
you were to take me in for an influence
MOT where would you where would you
start well having having seen your
profile Chris you're not doing too bad
my friend yeah it really starts with
finding out objectives I wouldn't I
wouldn't dream to think that everybody
wants the same thing so you know the
very first thing I do is is try and
understand their what and their y-you
know what is it they want to do what
does they want to be known for and why
is that important to them why is why is
that something that's gonna inspire and
motivate others if that's if that's the
the way they go about it so that would
be absolutely the first step is just to
understand people's objectives without
that you can't put any any real strategy
into place target to way might you'll
always miss right then that's the that's
the point if you're if if you're coming
at this from with it with an outcome in
mind but of course some people just want
to be nicer more effective in their
communication there might not be an
objective you could be retired and want
to communicate better that's fine but if
the premise you gave me was an overhaul
so coming in and maybe working with
somebody I'd be first looking to
understand what it is they're they're
looking to do and the reason of course
for that is that once you understand
your market place who you're looking to
get out there and you then need to
identify your audience where they play
the type of information they consume the
type of people that are already
influencing them so here the potential
collaborators and people you might be
able to take advantage of some of the
principles I talked about in the book
like credibility by association so
there's there's a whole load of load of
things that you might want to do and
once you're clear on why you want to do
it so we've established people's why
we'd start you to understand their
objectives and what they want to do
moving forward I think that is a that is
a massive stumbling block especially one
of the biggest routes to procrastination
is perfectionism it sounds it sounds
quite strange and quite circular but it
genuinely is that waiting until you have
everything in place or everything feels
perfect is a really
good excuse for procrastinating on
getting stuck getting started on a
project and of course that can have a
negative impact on influence as well and
I'm talking from personal experience
here my reason for procrastination is
very very aligned with what you just
said it's it's mainly because I like to
do the job myself because I know I I'll
do it the way I wanted no get it done
right yeah if you want to stop doing
right of course but then if what happens
is working life and everything else gets
in the way and yes suddenly overwhelmed
with jobs and you don't get around to it
and of course having somebody else do it
80 percent to the standard that you
would have done it is better than not
getting done at all so there's you know
there's a things around them agreed yeah
you need to I think I think especially
in business doubling down on your
strengths that said this in episode 8
with Michael cashew who's the CEO of
brute strength training and he said
himself his route to becoming one of the
biggest CrossFit programming operations
in the world was by doubling down on his
strengths and employing people who could
fill in where he's less capable or less
passionate and I think I think being a
jack-of-all-trades is it's really no use
to anybody in in a business context so
you've got me in we've we've had a look
at my objectives we've got around the
fact that I'm a perfectionist and that I
just need to I need to get moving where
do you go next
so from an influencer strategy point of
view the first thing I would do is sit
down and based on what you've told me
identify identify your audience and a
lot of a lot of people forget this but
you know in that that's um that's a bit
more complex then than we think because
you know we're we're living in times
where there are five different
generations in the workplace all with a
listener and that's never never been the
case before so we've got five different
generations in the workplace all with
different unique experiences and so
identifying your your audience is
important because we're we're more
multicultural than we've ever been
before
we're generationally divided and we've
never been before on that bear affects
all sorts of things like attitudes I
mean let me give you some examples of
why identifying your audience
properly is important definitely I'm
going to make one point at the end of it
but but I'm sure like me you are tired
of the term millennial yeah well I think
everybody's sick to death of the
terminal millennial but but I do think
it's important for all the generations
to understand what makes Millennials
tick I think it's equally important for
Millennials to try and understand why we
have we and I'm I'm not a millennial why
we have a different perspective to and
this this comes down to our experiences
so a couple a couple of quick stats to
throw out to you the average age for
marriage mortgage in kids in the 70s was
23 years old and today that's more like
36 years old so there's a lot of changes
what are you saying is that I've
actually still got time and that my
business partner can stop applying
pressure to me of course absolutely
and some of those reasons by the way
will be financial and you know and
because actually we have more we're more
experiential now and so we have the
world is our lobster Rodney you know we
can go anywhere we can we can do a
anything we want to do so we tend to put
off some of the other bigger decisions
because while we're young we want to
have those experiences
that's one student debt is another you
know there's a lot of reasons why those
things happen and so that's that's just
marriage mortgage and kids beyond that
work so in the u.s. only 7 percent of
Millennials work for fortune 500
companies and that's mainly because
Millennials who were of an age ready to
work want to be inspired by what they do
so they either start their own
businesses where they're connected to
their Y or they go and work for smaller
organizations where they're working
directly with the entrepreneur behind
the business so they can feel like
they're making a difference so that's
that's important to a generation and
then you know you look into things like
politics and we we live in an age of
great misinformation
where well you know where to where as as
divided as we've ever been when and you
know there's a whole lot of reasons for
that and we can go into that if you want
to or we can avoid it like the plague
and there whatever whatever Pandora's
Box we go into today is absolutely fine
whirring no problem so you know the
thing about missing an agent
misinformation is it makes actually all
of us that little bit more skeptical so
you know when we're told things our
first instincts now should be to not
believe it until we've actually seen
evidence or facts or something to
support it you know social media
absolutely dominates what we do it's
democracies you know conversations
really in its and it's made every every
opinion have its microphone you know and
so we have to be careful of what we take
in and believe and consumerism has
changed you know again Millennials and
in fact just coming to this point you
know the term millennial is quite often
accepted anybody after nineteen eighty
so it's 38 years and younger at the time
of recording this and the other things
happened since 1980 is the world
population has doubled so we're now over
seven billion people on the planet and
that's doubled in the last 38 years
which actually should scare the [ __ ] out
of anybody's really really should that
means half the world population are a
millennium monomial so yeah and so it's
now the most dominant consumer group
online you know from a consumer
consumerism point of view less brand
loyal you know if a brand they were
using every single day disappears
tomorrow that's fine they'll move on to
the next one but it'd be largely based
on things like social proof so your
reputation matters you know it's why we
we we read the reviews on Google on
Amazon on TripAdvisor and profile
testimonials on LinkedIn etc you know
we're interested in this stuff because
we want social proof we want to make the
best decision based on what our peers
recommend it's you know it's it's the
way it works so we've got all of that
going on and then we've got diversity
we're multiculturalism you know even
even faith is changing
you know when the UK we're becoming more
and more a theist in some European
countries it's almost totally atheist
yeah I mean even in the u.s. now I think
I read somewhere earlier this year that
you're it's less than 50% now the class
themself as white Christian in the u.s.
which is you know it was it was it was
never that you know such a dominant
demographic absolutely but the big point
I kind of want to make with this little
talk o Millennials and diversity is that
if you're talking to multiple
demographics if you're marketing to
multiple demographics but only using one
tone of voice with your communication
the harsh reality is you're not speaking
to everyone so if we want to be able to
reach different audiences and talk to
different demographics we have to
understand personalized and you know and
produce content and add value in in the
way that's meaningful to the people
you're trying to talk to and so many big
brands are still talking with one tone
of voice found it utterly surprising you
know we technology enables us to
personal I've got one one them friend
who I shall remain nameless for them but
he has a business a praying from London
and he works in a particular niche but
he identified within his database
recently that the day basic growing
quite large and that there were
something like four hundred John's for
argument's sake on a name so he took a
whiteboard any row and on video went
high jump and then he said hi John I
just wanted to tell you about and then
went on to speak to that particular
audience now every single Charlie
received that believed that was written
just for them to figure out but they
watched the video and maybe bought the
product yeah he then moved on to the
next biggest name on his list which was
you know whatever it was and then and
produce something for them so he what he
identified was you know by just
re-recording that one video a number of
times he still had caught up quite a big
reach but a much bigger and much bigger
conversion rate in the sense of a fit
sense of affinity was was through the
roof right absolutely it's personalized
so you need to gear the message to the
market I think so so understand your
audience is them is you're asking the
step we're in this consultative stage
we've come in we offender your what in
your wine understand your audience or
your audience is it could be plural and
it could be you know more than one
initial looking to operate in so
understanding that is the first thing
and then absolutely understanding where
they play so does that mean in terms of
media in media consumption events they
might attend now the news
Avenue zuv access that's absolute yeah
points to connect yep okay so that would
that would be that would be the next
step the next step after that I would
then be looking at all of the people who
already have influence over their
audience and I'd be very simply making
friends and maybe asking them to guest
post on a blog maybe interviewing them
for a podcast you know reaching out to
other influencers first of all is
flattering they're going to get some
profile it's a win-win there they're
going to let their audience listen to or
read your content so you get the
credibility by association thing that
comes and then what you're doing is
you're slowly building your audience and
building your influence towards that
audience because the key the only real
thing I think and nowadays is of long
term strategy when it comes to building
influence is to actually genuinely
trying add value yes you serve and that
could be from great content but you
really genuinely have to try and add
value to the audience you serve yeah I
couldn't I couldn't agree more I was
I've got a an upcoming live stream that
I'm gonna do an Instagram maybe tomorrow
when I'm driving I'm going down a
shropshire tomorrow and it's talking
about people who have a massive platform
online and choosing to use it for
reasons which add absolutely zero value
as far as I can see and the analogy that
I'm going to draw is that in the same
way as a strong person needs to
Tec the weak because it's a duty they
have a particular skill or a particular
they have a particular attribute which
is a travesty to not use when it's
called upon if you have a platform and
if you are looked up to and if you are
held in a position of credibility which
is increasingly being bestowed on people
who probably don't deserve it and you're
not using it to add value and to make
people's lives better as far as I'm
concerned it's a it's a bit of a
catastrophe and it's a real wasted
resource and it shows just how little
you do care for the audience that you've
got that's not for me to say like I'm
you know a with my small following
bestowing words of wisdom or something
like that but I am I'm trying to do my
best to speak forth something of value
something that the people that follow me
and that follow my friends and you know
introduce him to interesting people like
yourself that will enrich their lives
and help them make good lives better and
bad lives less less bad you know that
that seems great but yeah the the
prospect of having a platform and not
using it to me as sacrilege
I think so I'm often asked what um how
do i define a good speaker and let's
just assume the given is that they know
what they're talking about and you know
she's probably not just for that point
I'm gonna make like given so there are
two things which in my experience the
best speakers I've ever met have and the
first thing is an ego and I know that's
going to sound negative and it and it is
to a certain extent but if you're the
type of person I mean Chris you know
I've seen your Instagram account you
clearly care about what you're doing and
bit less clearly an ego in there as well
right um so having an ego isn't a bad
thing
as long as our desire to add value and
serve our audience is higher and bigger
than our ego
it's a very interesting point so the
best speakers I know stand up get a real
thrill from standing up on stage
absolutely they do but their desire to
affect change in others is bigger than
their ego hmm I think of some world
politicians right now mention their
names wouldn't it be amazing if they had
if they leverage the platform that's
come from you know their notoriety and
everything that they do because their
desire to effect change in others and
add value was bigger than their ego well
what a difference that would make
Wow they've the point that you've missed
there is that you're presuming that they
know what they're talking about that's a
very good point Touche my friend so yes
we've talked about the avenues of access
to the audience that we've defined we've
looked at our why where are we going to
next so then the next stage I would go
to we've we've added value we're
collaborating with other influencers so
we're starting to really build our reach
of the started to interject the
credibility by association thing which
you touched on earlier on I really
enjoyed in the book I think you're
totally correct when you see someone who
you follow how many times do you go out
and listen to a Joe Rogan podcast
Matthew Walker who wrote why we sleep
I'd seen why we sleep advertised and
Amazon had been ping to me off my Kindle
on my email but I listen to him on Joe
Rogan for three hours
obviously in and of himself he was very
charming and added a lot of value but
also the platform that Joe Rogan gave
him allowed me to be exposed to him
lended more credence more credibility to
what he was saying and I bought the book
while I was listening to him so there's
all there's a whole load of kind of
cliches on we're known by the company we
keep or we are the the kind of knit
product of the five people we hang
around the most with you know it's all
all of those ones which people know do
they really ring true for you they know
if I'm going to be really strict yes we
are known by the company we keep
absolutely positively and negatively but
the whole five five people that we hang
around the most with I think's nonsense
of course you know are they networks
aren't restricted to five people we know
not lots and lots and lots of people and
in different contexts we'll hang around
with different people you know if I'm if
I'm like the comedy course I went on to
the other week you know there's a
whatsapp group now over a whole load of
budding comedians having fun that's got
nothing to do my work it's got very
little to do with my home life or my
friends actually so we live in pockets
of interests and and we build
communities within our pockets of
interests and hopefully you know we're
multi-layered human beings with lots of
interest you try and take the best from
everyone right yeah do you know what I
mean even a lovely thing I mean I'm a
mid 40s guy right so I'm 45 years old
I'm 46 this year and you know the
speaking is one of the things I'm
passionate about there's this last month
I managed to speak up for a client in
Glasgow and what was really lovely is
that my dirty little secret is for the
last 14 years I've been an xbox fanatic
I managed to avoid it while I was
building a technology business in the in
the 90s and my wife and kids bought me
an xbox for my birthday which was a
really fatal thing to do Call of Duty
being my game of choice of course what
happens you start to make friends and
build a clan and and that happened
anyway I got up to Glasgow for this
speaking event and really brilliantly I
managed to meet up with some of my clan
and go out for a few beers and have a
bit of fun now some of these people I've
known really well for over 12 years but
have never met face to face a afk is it
known away from keyboard absolutely yeah
and so you know so you know it's not
it's it doesn't really matter how we
connect with others it just matters that
we do connect with others and I think I
think that's definitely
there's a lot to be said about we did it
recently a podcast on confidence and one
of the things that I tried to take away
from that was talking about being
truthful and being vulnerable to a
degree and I think that making it making
a genuine connection or committing to
making a genuine connection even if it's
only mostly going to be one way the
majority of social media is one is you
speaking and then some responses there's
more of you speaking than there are
responses for most most people online
but for you to add value personally I
think that there has to be a level of
vulnerability because presuming that you
genuinely care about what it is that
you're talking about you you have to be
very honest and very open and very
truthful with it that doesn't mean you
have to be completely transparent but it
does mean that you have to allow people
to see a very true true side of you and
I think that can probably be quite
daunting for a lot of people who are
concerned that their audience might not
like what they hear well it's also
daunting because it's not the way we're
being socially conditioned right now if
you think about it and social media is
people's highlight show real it's not
it's not real life but actually you
think about the biggest connections
you've ever had with somebody it's where
you've actually been vulnerable or you
know utterly honest and human that's
that's where we connect credibly
endearing trait well you know even as a
speaker one of the biggest weapons I'll
use on stage and is self deprecation I'm
quite happy to take them account myself
it really it really doesn't Tim doesn't
bother me at all but it but it does
relax an audience because suddenly
they're not thinking they listen to some
know-it-all on stage it's it's a human
being just sharing sharing the story and
that's that's the way she'd be very
brittle characteristic as well coming
back to the credibility by association
there because you mentioned one of the
stories in the book and and and actually
just so this this lens with your your
your audience there's a couple of quick
stories I'll tell one from the book on
one who's but one that isn't but for me
it comes back to this term about
understanding the power that's somebody
who already has profile either endorsing
you or taking you into the wing or being
seen with you the power that can have so
the story I talk about in the book is a
personal development
speaker author and actually to a certain
extent mentor to me when I was when I
was younger as a guy called Jack Black
not the no not the Hollywood Jack bass
region Jack Black who built a brand
called mind storm so it's it's it's all
about kind of personality and personal
development he was a social worker in
the 80s and he was fascinated by
personal development self so he started
developing his own content and when he
was ready to launch his own business he
saw the concept of credibility by
association he may not have called it
that but he he borrowed ten thousand
pounds and he put Sir John Harvey Jones
on stage next to him in front of 2,000
grams wage and business owners at a
conference or an event he was running
because he understood that Sir John
River Jones would be the draw but then
the moment he's on stage and he's on
stage with him he gets the credibility
that comes for that and overnight he was
the business guru that works with Sir
John Harvey Jones as a result built a
really good powerful business yeah you
may have heard the name Judy nake who
know who sold her business for seventeen
seventy five million
it was the she didn't even develop the
product because she had the distribution
rights to the San Tropez telling okay
timing stuff and yeah so for her I mean
she's quite an inspirational
businesswoman anyway because of the way
she dealt with people but she attributes
a lot of her success to having somebody
like Victoria Beckham walking out of the
store with a clear plastic bag and her
product in the bag and when I heard her
story it was within the months that
followed she did about two million in
sales just because of that one media
appearance you know so like that whole
credibility by association thing can be
really really powerful they can be used
it doesn't you know we're talking about
big things here like a seventy-five
million sale how does that apply to a
florist working in a town center or you
know or somebody just one as an
aspiration for a local business and
doesn't necessarily want to take it any
bigger for them it's really about
identifying the influencers locally if
you want more people to know you locally
try and find the people who have sway
who make recommendations day in day out
who are the net workers who are the
people that you can build relationships
with over coffee
just locally because they're
approachable you know these are these
are simple principles of concepts and
they can be applied at whatever level or
or whatever level of aspiration you have
for your business I understand I think
what we're obviously skirting around
here to a degree is the the very
overused term now of influencers mostly
used for social media you know the
number of product endorsements that you
get now is leveraging this exact
credibility by association isn't it you
look at for most of the the listeners
boohoo calm and a sauce and top man and
even giacomo and people like that are
trying to rebrand themselves by
attaching themselves to people that
Freddie Flintoff and you know I mean
like that they are this credibility by
association has become a major industry
in and of itself yes and you know it's
not it's not necessarily new I know an
influencer marketing is a more recent
term but you know I remember over a
decade ago when blackberry were one of
the dominant brands in mobile phones and
they had a they call it their ambassador
scheme but it was just influencer
marketing they identified people who
were prominent in loads of different
niches and I was I was one of them in
the small business sector because at the
time I was running a large business
network and you know it meant every
month I got them the next new shiny
phone - as you know as long as I shared
it wrote about it except etc so I was
one of the ambassadors amongst other
people but it you know that was that for
me was when I started to really notice
that you know this was a principle that
could be leveraged by anybody really so
by trying to get some credibility by
association here how how can we access
these people obviously by virtue of them
being in a position of existing
influence or potentially either a
different or a higher level of access to
network than we have
what are the one of the the effective
ways that someone can go about enticing
somebody in in terms of contact or if
they're meeting them face to face what
can they do to make them have more
confidence in their in the pitch so to
speak to become associated yes so this
is a good question this one I'm often
asked because of course nobody wants to
go reach out to somebody who's got sway
and influence and immediately be asking
for something that's the surefire way to
to turn them off and get them to ignore
everything that you do so you know most
people want to understand what makes you
tick your values your intentions before
they're going to invest any time into
you so that's the first thing I used to
sell sponsorship so you know with our
with our business Network brand we
managed to attract really nice
sponsorship figures from brands like
Santander blackberry o2 Microsoft etc
and you don't attract those brands
unless unless there's something in it
for them and so you always leave with
what's in it for them and I think this
is the this is the principle as well
when you're approaching people within
your network its seeking to add value
first so you know for example if I'd
already started to build an audience
tonight and I wanted to attract the
attention of them of an influencer I've
probably invited them to be interviewed
they're probably going to want to at
some level share their message they're
going to be flattered by the invitation
it's no different from you inviting me
on to this podcast Chris you know it's
nice to reach a different audience you
know that that works the whole principle
of credibility bias oceans that play
here by the way you know because I'm
sure you'll enjoy it when I share the
podcast with my audience because they
that broadens yours and you've already
got an audience which might be a
different demographic than I normally
talk to you so you know we both win from
it is we're both getting the credibility
by association from the conversation as
long as of course we're both not coming
across as more others whichever I choose
to believe we're not yeah
so you know approaching somebody I would
I would seek to add value first I would
I would have avoided a asking for
anything I would seek to add value and I
would avoid asking for anything that's
not in their interests if you know what
I mean yeah
that's a good starting point so um and
then of course you know once you've once
you've started that there's two two
things I would add to this journey of
influence that we started on because
we've got a seem you know you're one why
understand who your audience is identify
the influences in the marketplace add
value and collaborate and I would then
say there's only really two more steps
to this from an influencer strategy
point of view of course we can go into
lots more detail on any of those things
but as a as a broad strategy one is then
to continue to build your reach and
preferably on your own prep platform so
we rely so heavily on the platforms are
readily available to us like YouTube and
Facebook and what have you but don't you
know is quite turbulent they are
changing and because some of the
personal brands out there have become a
little bit more controversial they're
being deep platform so a unitless is now
off off twitter and yeah well he's been
off twitter for some time but um but but
actually yeah he was deep platform not
just from from Twitter but things like
Breitbart too you know so you know it's
it that the crowd can have that impact
so it's important for you to own your
own platform and or to to own your reach
own your relationship with your audience
rather than rely on somebody else would
be my advice interesting interesting in
ejection here I don't know whether you
follow much of what Tim Ferriss does yes
his he is his number one advocate of
email lists that he pushes everybody he
maximizes and he sings this that the
exact same hymn sheet that you are about
the algorithm on Facebook can change and
there's nothing that you can do about it
the reach on YouTube so on and so forth
everything is mediated by this third
party and I think that's one of the
reasons why he's such a big advocate of
getting maximising email as
description an email signup because it
is a direct line of communication from
him to his audience 100% and actually
it's not just restricted to things like
that I read somewhere recently that
Google's about to change their
algorithms yet again so it's not you
know you can have done as much as you
wanted to with SEO in the past but it's
not necessarily going to help you moving
forward and you know it's going to be
weighted in different ways so it's a you
know these are things that you
constantly have to keep on top of but
owning your relationship with your
audience is massively important how else
can someone ensure that they are in the
relationship with their audience are all
in their platform as you put it
so specifically to answer that question
I would I would be wherever possible
taking them away from the places that
you met them in the first place and
building that subscription so Tim what
Tim does is he'll go and play on social
media he has lots of referral schemes in
place he relies on his audience to help
and build his audience too but he will
he will give you something of value but
in order to get that something of value
you're subscribing so it could be a 10
top tips on how to whatever but you
party apart with your email address and
then he makes it very clear I'm going to
send you something of value on a regular
basis if you if you don't want that
thing of value then you don't have the
awesome no problem but no but if you do
then know why you're doing this it's not
me spamming I'm sending you something of
value yeah so you know it's being really
clear with intentions and you know the
point is that all of the hard work
should have been done before that stage
you know the people you're talking to
should understand your values they
should understand the value you bring to
them and therefore you know when they
subscribed it's it's a consensual act
they've got a feeling of certainty and
safety that they're buying into
something that they value absolutely
absolutely ok so and then the last step
I would take beyond Bill Munich
continuing to build you reach and own
your platform would be to you know
productize take advantage of what you've
built productized then rinse and repeat
you know all of those steps you can
continuously go through them and you
know you should be on a regular basis as
the world changes around you
visiting your what on you why and how
your audience is changing and therefore
you know where are they playing now
what's the change in technology or
social media that they've moved on to
you know who are the new influences who
can you give a helping hand to who might
be bringing a new audience with them add
value collaborate continue to build your
reach productize rinse and repeat I
think what I like about that particular
layout is that the productize comes at
the end and they're operating a freemium
model or over delivering on the front
end as it's known in the online
marketing world is a commonly a commonly
used approach now and as you say exactly
exactly right with Tim Ferriss what you
get you get an awful lot of value for a
very little investment ie something
that's free you giving your email across
but the content that you get is very
very highly valued and that the
productizing or the turning that into a
financial or business in quotation marks
plan almost becomes it emerges
organically out of all of the steps that
you've built upon that you've got this
level of credibility that you have good
access to market that you understand the
audience that you're speaking to yeah
and so boss productize is at the end in
that simple model actually the reality
is you do all of those things all at the
same time yeah you know it's nice and
easy to sort of spell out in steps but
of course if you've got a product or
service to sell you're going to sell it
to the audience that you've got the time
you start really and you know you know
it but you're right what you know the
considerations up until the point of
product isin selling something is making
sure that you've got something is truly
a value and it's a consensual act you
know that your audience wants it but no
that's a very simple philosophy on on
the whole thing I mean as I say the
world has changed you know influence has
changed massively and what most people
perceive to be the change might just be
societal but actually we've had changes
and technology's impacted business you
know it's a nice little stat that over
40
sent at the companies at the top of the
fortune 500 in the year 2001 no longer
there in the year 2010 is that true
that's true and and you know even on top
of that you've got brands that have come
from nowhere which you know we've all
heard of and know off like the ubers and
the Airbnb s who have come from nowhere
Worth absolute fortunes but don't
necessarily having the product or
service they only access to the product
or service so they they have the
influence over the audience you know it
was the biggest fleet of cars in the
world they don't own a car
yeah Airbnb is the biggest portfolio
property in the world they don't own a
property I think and I think Ali Baba's
the same but for retail yeah sure sure
and you know and the Amazon the same
thing for retail as well you know it's
the people who own the relationship with
the customer and with the audience and
of course they're their own platforms I
think they've built their own plant they
are they on platform you and they in the
relationship so you know that's
absolutely and telling and you know this
the opposite is true I mean think think
of brands that that should have done it
I mean yelled calm so were yellow pages
you know yell go , actually doing some
really quite good stuff now around small
business marketing websites SEO and all
that type of thing they are doing some
good things but but actually considering
they started in 1956 ahead of everyone
else well in Brighton and they started
with the Yellow Pages they suddenly grew
they eventually grew into four
continents and they dominated search the
internet came along and there was nobody
saying how's this internet thing gonna
affect our business they should have
been Google but they weren't blockbuster
the same blockbuster very similar Kodak
very similar Kodak actually invented the
digital camera the thing that we all
walk around with in our pockets and just
call a phone but it's a and I recall
multi-purpose device they invented the
digital camera and they even brought
futurists into their business in the 80s
and said what's the future of digital
what's the future of photography and of
course they said the futures digital and
they said that's no we move what we
wanted to hear you're fine you know so
that it was a load of people that I'm
really close minded to the change that's
happening on random but it's
but it's it's it's not just technology
that's changes in fact one of the
examples I use on stage I'll give you it
now there's a barometer for how long it
takes a product or service to reach 50
million users okay so for the telephone
it was 75 years for the radio it was 38
years for the TV it was 13 years the
iPod did it in for the Internet did it
in 3 Facebook did it into the iPhone did
it in 3 months now if you think about it
every single one of those isn't
innovation in communication it's an
innovation in the way that we
communicate and influence it's a
different broadcast medium and just to
evidence the 3 months it took the iPhone
it to Angry Birds 30 days that's that's
the that's the kind of you know the
speed of change as it happens yeah III
think it's terrifying isn't it and I
suppose that it almost becomes each of
those levels of communication and how
open global communication is now permit
this to catalyze itself further it'll
only mean that this gets further
expedited and that these these
timeframes are going to become even more
shortened because you can find out about
something so much more quickly than you
ever could before all or not you can
find out the falsehood that's the
disinformation becomes absolutely yes so
I wanted to talk about personal brands
and how people how people display
themselves post both online and in
person I know you in the book you touch
on ways to dress colors and how they
elicit different emotions and different
sort of ties and outfits
neuro-linguistic programming body
language let's start with how you can
make a good impression face to face I
know a lot of people when we talk about
influence may be thinking about what
happens online and that may be a high
volume of the traffic that goes
backwards and forwards
but certainly for me when I meet when I
meet with other business people and
people of influence who are good
face-to-face they leave a very marked
impression on me
in a different way to someone who's good
online does it seems to be a much a much
rarer skillset it's it's a much rarer
skill set but it's going to be the one
which I believe will be utterly
in-demand in the next couple of decades
why the line I use on stage is in an age
of automation artificial intelligence a
robot ization stay human yes I you know
the point which I want people to
understand is that you know we are
becoming more disconnected from each
other you know
counter-intuitively because we're more
connected you know biotechnology but
we're actually more disconnected on a
human level because it's as we said
everyone is highlight reels that have
been shared it's it's superficial
stories it's summaries rather than in
in-depth conversations you know people
are projecting them but their best
selves rather than their vulnerable
cells if you know what I mean so they're
not doing the human thing and so I
believe one of the core competencies one
of the core skills that you can you can
go and develop no matter what industry
you're in and what level you want to
achieve within the industry if you want
to be more effective with all of your
relationships then you need to become a
student of people and that includes
yourself understand who you are and then
be authentic to that but under
understand other people and adapt how
you communicate with them to their
preferences so there's a number of tools
for that which we can unpack if you want
to yes please but but that's the that's
I think I think it's going to be the
most important skill and and even on a
big brand kind of corporate level it's
gonna be about demonstrating values and
telling stories because that's how we're
going to be connecting with people more
and more so to unpack the original bit
where communication starts off I'll tell
you a couple of things first of all
let's talk about what the communication
model is have the process of
communication so we have
and very very very easily we have
external stimuli it comes in it can be
in a number of different formats and
will receive that and process it through
our kind of visual auditory kinesthetic
even even through you know things like
text you know will interpret the world
around us in a number of different ways
but let's say mainly through our eyes
ears and you know what what we sense um
what we feel yeah
and then what happens is we apply our
normal filters so our filters will
generalize distort and delete you know
they will they will map that information
against our own values our social
conditioning the beliefs that we hold
and the memories that we have you know
we are a product of our environment is
the whole kind of conversation around
nature and nurture I think it's in most
cases nurture will win every single time
so we are a product of our environment
but anyway all of those things
they basically constitute our map of
reality this was once them highlighted
to me quite recently actually where
somebody had come into a friend of mine
he was he was coaching and she was
coaching this particular client and they
sent him I want to be a better
communicator a better speaker she said
okay well we need to work on your
confidence and she says oh no I don't to
work on my confidence yeah so why don't
work on your confidence because I don't
want to come across as arrogant so in
her map of reality the word confidence
means arrogant assumption that we always
make is that everybody thinks the same
way that we do or or uses language in
the same way that we do or has
interpreted the world around them and
the same way that we have and it's a
kind of fatal mistake so the
communication model is it comes in
external stimuli we put it through our
filters map against you know our map of
reality this affects our physical state
and therefore our physiology and
therefore it impacts the way we behave
that's the simple process of
communication okay okay the next thing
is really around then how how we
internally process information so if you
can understand somebody's preference to
things like visual auditory kinesthetic
or even you know those that are real
logic thinkers this is
touching on some of the things that NLP
will will teach you know if you're if
you're dealing with somebody who has a
strong visual preference and you can
identify that you can use language like
do you see what I mean well can you see
that can you see the big picture you
know you'll use visual language and
you'd probably be a little bit more
effective with them somebody's got an
auditory preference and how they process
information it was do you hear what I'm
saying
if it's feelings you know
you know I get the feeling that and you
can use those language you know how does
that feel to you for example so the key
is how you identify people's
representation I was going to say how do
you how do you determine that there's a
number of tools and then before I tell
you before I give you the answer to that
because it's um you know there's a
there's another one level of complex
yeah I don't if you've ever done
psychometrics Chris I have a disc
profile something like I've done big
five which is a personality assessment
I'm not sure if that counts you know I
encourage everybody to go off and do
these things because there's a there's a
always going to be a slight improvement
in self-awareness that comes from it
what would you recommend
so disc is the is the the one that's
best known but you know this
myers-briggs says Belbin they're all
good for different contexts disc is the
one that's really known and quite often
used by other tools too they adapt they
take the standard core of it when they
apply different learnings you know the
thing about these things is they'll put
you into a into a box for the sake of
overview analytics but actually we all
have adaptive behaviors too and and we
all you know floating between different
for example I'm a I'm a high I in disc
which is energetic big-picture
enthusiastic outgoing all of those
things but but actually if I come across
somebody who's very dominant and task
focus and strong-willed and forceful
I'll adapt my behavior to ultra dominate
them if you know what I mean cuz I don't
know I don't like being dominated if
behavior will be to Tim to match theirs
but it will all it will always be our
adaptive behaviors are also also always
very true time
you stay there anchored to our values
but again they said it's a thing to
understand so for example in the sales
context if if I was going into a sales
meeting and I meet somebody like me
we're going to have a a bit of a laugh
we're going to have banter we're going
to be telling stories you know it's
talking big big picture it's going to be
enthusiastic and and positive and if I
go in and speak to somebody who's highly
analytical with a strong preference for
detail I immediately will adapt the way
I'm communicating and I'll get to the
point first I'll do the numbers and you
know otherwise if I'm doing my usual
thing they'll just be thinking just get
on with it numbers give me the details
they'll be distracted by that so you
have to adapt the way that you speak to
others to match their communication
preferences okay so how will we how are
you going to determine who these people
are so I'm going to give you two to two
obvious methods and well one obvious
method and one which isn't so obvious
there's something called I access in
queues which I find quite useful I use
it quite a lot in my just day-to-day
rapport with other people and this is
the have you seen the TV series lied to
me with Tim Roth yes yep so of course he
uses a whole load of tools which are
psychological tools understanding
thought processes body language etc I
access and tools is one of them and
basically if you're speaking to somebody
and they wear their eyes go gives you a
bit of an indication into their
communication preference so imagine
you're looking at somebody and their
eyes go top right-hand corner so their
top left top idea that's visual recall
so they're they're accessing memories if
it goes to the other side is visual
construct that's imagination often
misused by police forces who think
people are constructing alibis if they
spend a lot of time there remember it's
not an exact science it's just a good
way of understanding a preference so if
they're if they stay dead even but go to
the left and so I go to the right as
facing that's auditory recall so
remembering what somebody said to the
left is order to reconstruct imagining
what somebody might say if it goes to
the bottom righthand car outside that's
internal dialogue that's probably some
very strong logical thinker who's
actually asking themselves the question
and program trying to figure out what
their answer is if it's the opposite
side bottom left that's kinesthetic
touch taste smell etc so there's
somebody very connected to their
feelings and typically somebody's a
strong kinesthetic thinker will be
slower in their communication because
they're feeling it so that's that's one
example but you know the really simple
way of understanding somebody's
preference with all of these things is
to listen yeah honestly it's not more
complex than that asking really good
questions and listening you see on top
of communication and representational
systems the thing which I really go off
about is context everybody has a context
everybody has a set of circumstances are
really unique to them and the only way
we get to understand people's
communication preferences personality
types and their context is to ask them
really good questions they did a study
where they took a chap who was flying
transatlantic Lee from New York to the
UK and this could be just an urban myth
by the way but I've been telling the
story it's because I heard it years ago
and thought because I thought it was
cool but this person was flying
transatlantic leave New York to the UK
seven hours on the fly and they gave him
the task that you've got to keep the guy
next to you talking for the whole seven
hours or without which without revealing
a single piece of information about
yourself Wow so when they landed they
interviewed the guy the other passenger
me so how was your flight
it was amazing it's really good I was
happy talking to you oh what a fella
really cool guy what was his name
couldn't tell you didn't have a
scooby-doo hadn't given them any
information at all he'd just sown such
such genuine interest that this person
had been made to feel like a million
dollars so you have two byproducts of
asking good questions and being
interested in people one is you get to
learn their personality preferences
representational systems and context the
second is they really like you because
you've shown interest in them they feel
special and so it has is a double-edged
sword it works really really well you
networking context I meet people who are
nervous about networking all the time
and you know networking can be daunting
and there's no two ways around it but
actually if you just get good at asking
people questions and showing genuine
interest in people and it's no different
from dating Chris is it you know and if
I if finally these tools when I was 60
and 70 it's a much different teenage
teenage years just show interesting
people you know make them feel special
by showing genuine interest it's the key
to all things I think you're very right
everyone everyone knows everyone's got
that friend who just won't show up about
what they've got going on and no one
really wants to be around them or they
tolerate them to varying degrees but
yeah when I think about the people who I
have the most connection with it's the
ones who ask questions who ask me how
I'm doing or how my day is going I'll
follow up something they don't just ask
your question to be polite they take a
genuine interest and then they ask again
and then they ask again yes well I'll
quote Buddha if your mouth is open
you're not learning very fair point very
fair point so we've had a look at how we
can interpret what category someone else
would fall into so that they can you can
gear your use of language towards that
what are the things that you can do
yourself after asking questions in terms
of body language in terms of dress in
terms of I I contact word usage what are
the things that you can do to give the
the best impression of yourself face to
face so so we we talked talked about
getting into rapport with somebody and
there's a there's a number of different
ways of getting into rapport but let's
start with the physiology so we rapport
is that kind of act at that time of
connection with somebody where you know
you're starting to build trust so from a
physiology point of view simple things
like blinking and breathing at the same
pace
on a subconscious level is that easy to
do oh well you know the key with all of
these things is if you if you force it
and you're obvious with it it feels like
manipulation and it will have the
opposite effect it will be able to turn
somebody off it breaks down the fourth
wall yeah but if you if you if you come
in to a situation with somebody and you
genuinely just want to try and be
synchronized that's that's that's a
different thing altogether in fact the
biggest way of you know I'm going to
tell you a few things about rapport now
but actually the biggest way of building
rapport with somebody is when you're
asking all of those great questions we
just talked about genuinely listen to
their answer you know if you're really
listening to somebody you'll naturally
fall into rapport with them anyway I
thanked I was a an exhibition in London
called the best you big shout out to
Bernardo Moyer who runs that event in
London every area and I was talking I
had a speaking there but I had a stand
as well so I was on the stand talking to
people I was talking to this woman who's
really really skeptical about anything
to do with things like rapport and after
about 10 minutes she had kind of relaxed
him show more interest and I just
highlighted to her that we were stood in
exactly the same pose which was my hand
was on my midsection kind of holding the
buckle of my belt and she she had come
into that same pose and she said well
you've just put your hands there I've
been stood this way it's reverse Kevin
go I said actually I've been stood like
this for an hour my belt broke an hour
ago I've been holding my trousers up
you've you've fallen into rapport with
me and you know it does happen it's
because on a subconscious level we do
actually want to connect with other
people so the the whole blinking and
breathing thing is is a a nice gentle
way of doing it
I'd be expressioned on our faces you
know being in control of our own
expressions having a smile on our face
you know all of all of those things is
is easy to do yet people don't do it but
it's got to be an authentic smile as
well and so two quick things on this I
was once in an audience as I'm speaking
to an audience and a guy in the audience
had this grimace on his face the whole
way through my talk and as a speak I'm a
try and make eye contact with everybody
and I immediately thought god this guy
hates what I'm saying here and at the
end of the talk
you know his facial expression hadn't
changed and the end of talk he came up
to and he said that was one of the best
presentations I've ever heard you have
forgotten to tell your face my friend
and utterly confused me with that
response and you know we were in control
of our expressions so if you want to
make friends with people and build
rapport and of course you know just
relax into it one of the people who
didn't do this authentically there was
some previous PM Gordon Brown so Gordon
Brown and one of the elections was
basically advised by somebody within his
team to go and practice his smile and
before the cameras were turned up at one
of the BBC election debates in Bristol
he stood at the lectern for about 15
minutes practicing his smile which just
didn't look natural at all so this is
where you've got to get the balance
right with who you authentically are
yeah and but anyway moving on then
you've got things like the nonverbal our
gestures and so you know our reptilian
brains if you approached somebody with
your hands behind your back their
immediate subconscious thought is what
are you hiding what weapon are you gonna
pull out and quickly over the head with
exactly so open body language positive
body language you know bird then being
mindful about what different gestures me
mean in different countries it got quick
funny a friend of mine Steve Clark was
speaking in Tehran and in Tehran he said
one of the things Steve's puts his
thumbs up all the time you know he's is
that all right yeah yeah as a speaker
and it made a point and then put his
thumbs up now in in Iran if you put your
thumb up at somebody you're flipping the
bird you're doing the entire auditorium
well four hundred people in an audience
who had just flipped and you know
consistently carried on doing it and
their whole facial expressions changed
and he was saved by his translator who
said he doesn't know what he's just done
in their ears and then they started
laughing and it was rescued but you know
just be mindful but open body language
show your hands and I'm often asked
actually in an age of
video conference calls and Skype calls
where people aren't traveling as much
but still wanting to connect how can you
do the same thing so you know the same
thing applies if you're gonna take the
I've where I talk about image in the
book it's not just about brand it's not
just about profiles and pictures or the
way that you address it's also the way
you set the room you're speaking in
what's the impression the reason I asked
you for this particular thing is in
audio or was it a video because if it
was really odd had done it somewhere
else you know because I'd have been
mindful of the scene that we set as well
and so again the thing about a Skype
call is you can still show your hands
you can still make eye contact by
looking directly into the camera at the
moment you start getting distracted and
reading emails and not giving your
attention to the person you're talking
to then you know you'll you're gonna
lose some of that ability to influence
it's interesting that the principles of
face-to-face communication occur even
when the other face is coming through a
screen absolutely absolutely so I always
minimize the picture of the other person
and put it right up by the camera so a a
I'm watching their face but it you know
my eyes are looking into their eyes
that's a really good that's a really
good little tip isn't it again I think
it's important you know we've got we've
got to if we're going to use adapt the
way that we we behave and communicate to
technology then we still have to use in
applying your principle so that's the
point point of the book really so the
nonverbal includes posture you'll have
heard people doing power poses and close
to body language arms folded etc you
know but don't read too much into these
things all the time you know unlike you
case I've seen I've seen your pictures
on anywhere mind body soul fitness
phonetic I'm a I'm a overweight mid-40s
guy so sometimes I think box though good
on xbox but sometimes I felt my arms
because it's comfortable I've got a
little belly I can rest my arms on you
know so it's it's different offices for
different courses and you may have even
seen recently where a load of the Tory
MPs have been stood in power poses where
they like legs far too far apart they
look like aging power ranges you know
they're so you know again to be avoided
and you know eye contact common sense
little and often you know if you
intensely stare into somebody's eyes
constantly you're going to freak them
out so use it when you're being sincere
and thankfully when I'm talking to
somebody I look into their eyes when I'm
listening somebody i watch their mouth
so is that a fairly good rule of thumb
it's just the way I do it and by you
know I know that if they sit if there's
background noise and things if I'm
reading some watching somebody's mouth
I'm really taking in what they're saying
I'm concentrated on the words and I'm
receiving the words in more than one way
but if I'm talking to them I'm looking
into their eyes and and showing I'm not
hiding behind anything the moment you
start looking away when you're actually
talking and you know that that could
breed a lack of trust I do find it
sometimes very difficult I work I work
quite hard on um on maintaining eye
contact especially having read having
read the book but the hitting that
Goldilocks zone of not too much to look
like you want to fight but enough to
show that you're engaged I there's still
a question mark I guess that hangs over
with regards to that sometime but well
the easy thing is you know if you're in
control of all the other assets you have
ie you're smiling very rare to people
look for a fight with a smile on the
face you know so it's it's just
combining combining the lot that you
know and enough for them to know that
you're actually involved in that
conversation with them and not
distracted about what's going on over
their shoulders is the thing and then
you know from nonverbal I'd come on to
voice so with with voices a whole load
of things that we can do our pacing our
volume the language that we use the tone
that we use the different intonation
that we use so you know if I'm if I go
and meet somebody for example
particularly for the first time and
they're all frantic and stressed I might
match that intensity initially but then
I'll slow myself down and slow them down
with me so by the time we finished
they're nice and relaxed and when
rapport and we're having a conversation
and everybody's been calmed down but if
I go in and start trying to be too
common issue am I not getting to rapport
with them as quickly because I'm
subconsciously I'm not just like them
equally if I'm stressed and manic
because I'm late for a meeting and I
come in and somebody's on calm and calm
and relaxed you know the first thing I'm
doing is giving myself a sanity check
and by taking up taking a breath and
slowing down my communication yeah so
that you know little things like that
and I sneeze Ian's language is easy you
know language is around the words that
we use compliments are free but just
make them genuine because if you just
start saying nice things for the sake of
it it comes across as insincere so you
know if you're in a job that's in
somebody's like you you find yourself in
people's homes or if you go into
somebody's office and they've got a
picture of their their family ask
questions but ourselves lovely family
got their lovely home you have or
whatever the compliment is just mean it
so little things like that help but
language can get more complex so with
NLP and language patterns are important
parts of it and embedded commands are an
important part of that a very skilled
politician who used to do that in my
opinion was Tony Blair and regardless of
whether we agree with his politics he
was very skilled at using language he
would he would say something like you
like me believe it's important for us to
have a robust economy
well the embedded commands there is you
like me you like me believe and that you
like me is was it with enough pause and
for the command to actually sink in onyx
of quiet never even noticed that but I
can I can literally picture that I can
picture him saying that I'm pointing at
the screen he was he was clearly trained
in things like NLP his the way his body
language the way he sometimes you could
see throw but actually most of the time
he did it very naturally and so it's
clearly been trained or he was just a
very natural at it we remember you know
NLP in itself its origins come from
modeling the behavior of people who were
good at what they want they just yet
it's trying to it's trying to recreate
someone who naturally has that good
rapport building I suppose are there any
other NLP tricks or
solutions that people can implement
obviously hopefully not once that are
going to be too conceited or spurious
but yeah ones that that people could use
to to assist them when they're trying to
build rapport and so well think about
what we've covered so far so we've
covered report from a physiologic
pontiff here from a nonverbal point of
view and from a voice point of view one
of the things which I think people
should in fact we've already said it
today I'm going to repeat something is
important it's around connection on a
human level so demonstrating your values
is a reason why you know with my acronym
in the book the Y is around you and it's
around values and the character traits
that you display I believe it's
important to wear those values on your
sleeve I used to have a business card
actually on the back of the business
card at hand all the words that defined
me so you know West Ham United seeing
the family you know kids father guitar
whatever the words which which which
floated my boat and what would happen is
people typically a few exchange of
business card in a meeting or networking
around they'll turn the card over and
immediately the conversation would be
people orientated on one of those
subjects rather than actually just
trying to be formal and businesslike and
it made the rest of the meetings so much
easier because we've got to relate on a
human level rather than actually trying
to talk business straight away I
understand
so that whole connection thing with with
other people can come from a number of
different ways it can come because
you've shown interest it can come
because you've been able to wear your
heart on your sleeve your values on your
sleeve
I'll give me an example of this actually
I was coming this is a few years bank
but when my kids were younger we were
coming back from Euro Disney on the
train and my wife's an introvert so she
just wanted to put her head into a book
and read and relax and greet you know
re-energized by having her alone time
which is how introverts we Emma Giants
and extroverts like me weary energized
by throwing ourselves into groups of
people you know so in this particular
case she wanted to read a book I was
entertaining the kids and before you
knew it I started to attract other
people's children I know that sounds
wrong but
from my point of view card games drawing
you know entertainment whatever so I
suddenly had a little audience and I
looked after these these kids on the way
and coming into London and about 20
minutes outside of a London train
station
one of the other dad said I'm intrigued
what was it you do and we had a
conversation which resulted in business
a couple of weeks later no way he saw my
values he could see how I was coming
across he could see what I was like with
my own children he could say I was
generous enough to give time and
attention to other people's kids you
know the values were plain and simple
and clear and you know that that just
made the rest of the conversation nice
and easy and you know when I when we
talk about things like serendipity not
being a strategy serendipity is
effective if if there's still not a
strategy but it's still effective if you
if you can make the most of
opportunities because you come across in
the right way and and then actually if
you've got things front of mind one of
my favorite sayings is opportunity
dances with those already on the dance
floor
mm-hmm yeah which I which I think is
about translated is just about having
your wants needs desires front of mind
if you remind yourself on a regular
basis what you're looking for you're
more likely to spot it does it look
equals preparedness Plus opportunity yes
absolutely yes it's it really
serendipity but then you know the very
last thing which I'll give you and just
just on this this influencing
face-to-face is is rather than
approaching conversations in the
transactional way you know you tell me
something I'm going to tell you
something you tell me something I'm
going to tell you something and it's
going to serve a purpose becomes like a
game of tennis right absolutely start
telling stories I believe one of the the
core competencies of big brands small
brands personal brands alike for the
next decade or so is going to be your
ability to tell your stories which
demonstrate your values which connect on
a human level so get great a
storytelling that's new what's at oh
it's a really good example of that is
how successful John Lewis have been with
their Christmas commercials amazingly so
yeah absolutely
yeah they're drawing people in on it on
a subject rather than just saying
this is what we've got on the shelves
and this is the price we're selling here
it's about storytelling it's no
different in face-to-face conversations
and if you think about this conversation
we've had so far we've told stories of
Tony Blair Gordon Brown we've told
stories of Euro Disney we've talked
stories of Jack Black
Judy nail you know we've we've told
stories of business cards of people with
different psychometric profiles of
Millennials you know it's all it's all
about storytelling I understand
completely so I think we've got a good a
good understanding of what people can do
face to face there what are the other
principles of influence that you think
that we haven't covered so far which are
pertinent for people to understand so in
the book I everything down into an
acronym called picky and that's mainly
because it's it's in the rule book for
speakers or writers that you've got to
have an acronym you're not allowed to do
otherwise
so I'll just quickly run through the
acronym and it will just give you an
idea of the bigger picture so P is
around people and they said this we've
touched on it with how we connect with
influences but it's not necessarily just
influences that bring us opportunities
knowledge wisdom critical feedback etc
so it's our networks and you know I'd
encourage anybody who is listening to
this to start taking their networking a
little bit more seriously that doesn't
necessarily mean going to breakfast
networking events it means just being a
bit more focused on on building your
your sphere of influence the
relationships that you have the people
that you would know and who would know
you and it's like what was it that you
say in the book it's it's not who you
know or what you know it who knows it's
also who knows you 100% and so for I
take this quite seriously I run a skiing
trip every year called net ski in fact
we're about 13 years old now so we take
a bunch of business people I think the
biggest group we've done was nearly 70 a
bunch of business people to a resort
typically in in Europe and of course
they're bonding over a shared experience
then you know they're not
not sales pitching to each other
nobody's immediately bringing business
cards to dinner on an evening you know
they're having a glass of wine working
hard in the day laughing at the the
mistakes high-fiving over the triumphs
and is a shared experience they're
connecting on a human level and no meat
anymore business gets done on that trip
and afterwards and any other networking
event I've ever seen yeah I bet it does
I think going just briefly jumping back
to what you'd said previously about the
story telling that it's strange isn't it
that really effective outcomes from a
commercial perspective in quotation
marks are elicited by not focusing on
that at all by focusing on the values
and focusing on the story and yeah I
definitely I definitely can see some
parallels in my business life with that
and I would say I don't I don't know
where your audience is geographically
but if you've just heard that and
thought eh I want to be a part of it I'm
going to shamelessly plug its net -
skied or cool at UK and one well we've
got two trips next year we're doing team
in January and we're doing Aspen in
March and so we we have this there's not
many places left for team but that we do
have the option of taking the Chalet
next door but it's my point is it's a
really good trip because people you know
all of that travel time all of that time
and chair lifts all the sneaky beers all
all then show you have you know in
between runs you know it's those
experiences that it's that's the bits
where people bond and then take that to
another level then I'm a huge fan of
masterminding are you part of a
mastermind Chris no have you heard of it
as a concept I would like it elaborated
I have I wouldn't be able to recite it
to you okay so that I first presented
introduced to masterminds when I was
probably about 18 19 years old and I was
it was Christmas Christmas Eve I was in
a pub in Wiltshire and I was just stood
with one of my best mates and his dad
and his dad you know millionaire
business owner and you know we were
doing all of our kind of young spouting
spouting [ __ ] as young people do as I
did anyway
and he said well if you're really
ambitious war and he said Jill then you
know it's a book I recommend and it was
thinking Grow Rich by Napoleon Hill and
he said I could lend you my copy but if
you're hungry enough you're going by
your own and of course you know wanting
to be seen as hungry I had thought I
think I added by Boxing Day but there
was a chapter in there around
masterminding which I thought oh this is
really really powerful impressive and
it's the simple concept of bringing some
really good people together on a fairly
regular basis that could be monthly or
every two months and actually being that
kind of sounding board for each other
being the you know like the board of
directors for each other and so you know
it's the if you've got an idea where
your incubator if you've got an issue
you're dealing with a colleague or
worker fellow director a member of staff
what are they even even at home there
your critical feedback they listen and
you know will come in with a different
perspective if you're great creating
commercial opportunities they may be JV
partners potentially or they may have
the context to make it happen but is
that sitting down for a period of time
with a bunch of people you respect and
value their opinion and being open and
honest enough and vulnerable enough to
share and there's two rules to it one is
Champ House Rules so whatever is said in
that environment stays in their
environment you don't go talking behind
each other's back Trust isn't absolutely
important for it to work but the second
thing that really happens is
accountability so if you're with a bunch
of people and you you say oh I'm gonna
go and do this by next month you don't
want to turn up next month having not
done it so that accountability means
that you get things done there were
organizations out there you can go and
spend lots of money on on masterminding
you know Vistage is one of the bigger
ones as the Academy chief execs and
loads of others but you know can't cost
anything up to a thousand pound a month
to be part part of these groups and I
have paid that much in the past but
actually you can equally go and invite a
bunch of people you like to the pub once
a month and just have dinner together
and have that same conversation you know
it doesn't have to
I've currently got a really nice
mastermind group as we've we've kept it
to five for now but for me it's an
essential part of running a business or
building a personal brand you know
collaborations and all sorts of things
come out of it but it's a group of
people that you really trust to get
dynamite advice so that's taking
networking to to a bigger level is you
know don't just see it as a kind of
transactional business breakfast type
thing see it about building to let the
human relationships and then if you can
find that kind of core group of people
that you really value the opinion of
start start meeting them on a more
intimate setting and bring your issues
to the table yeah when you find when you
find someone who can add a little bit of
value don't don't let them go absolutely
don't get a hold of them and try and
trying to meet them as regularly as
possible so we've got P people what's I
for people I surround image so we've
touched on it before but it's you know
the way we present ourselves it's the
way the clothes we wear it's the it's
the the way that we dress our profile
pages on social media you know astounds
me that I still see people who've got
profile pictures from 20 30 years ago
and they've lost all their hair since
then or well but whatever the thing is
you know again it's got to be authentic
if I turn up on her and my wife won't
let me go on dating sites but if I was
to turn up on a dating site and somebody
turns up and their pictures 20 years out
of out of date what does that tell me
from a trust point of view you know it
means that they they hide the you know
in the same is true in business you know
if you if you if you try and portray an
image that's not you actually
immediately makes people more skeptical
of you anyway so images about all of
those things is consideration to the
language that we use the words that we
use on our copy on our websites on our
business cards on our sales literature
on our email marketing our newsletters
etc images around the kind of values
that we want to portray communication is
the see and that's around how we you
know how we have conversations again
both both written and our language face
to face and for me a big key part of
that is being consistent you know I see
people on social media for example safe
be behind a monitor and a keyboard in
another County and say things that they
wouldn't dream of saying if they were
staring into the whites of somebody's
eyes great and again I think it's really
important to be consistent and just have
that filter that says would I say this
if I was staring into that bars right
now if I wouldn't them down right it you
know it little things like that that's a
lovely lovely rule of thumb that I wish
most of the internet would listen to
unfortunately they won't make me god of
the internet so I can't do anything
about our only hope god help the world
kazar knowledge and that's a simple
thing around demonstrating expertise you
know so if we were if we were looking to
breed trust with somebody we want to
they want to know that we know what
we're talking about so how do we
demonstrate on our expertise how do we
how do we share our knowledge how do we
leverage all of those all of the
principles that we've talked about today
and again this multiple channels open to
us but I really encourage people to get
out of their comfort zones and stand up
in public speak if if it's if it's in
you if you think it's possibly in you
you know standing up and actually
speaking to your peers is one of the
most powerful ways to breed authority
and there and then lastly we've touched
on already is the why which is around
the values that we we hold and in the
book I explore a load of values which M
which I identified in the people that
have influenced me and again just in the
in the interest of modeling having
identified them I gave them great
thought and thought you know how can I
start to adopt these values and how can
i how can I purchase early demonstrate
those values so really simple you know
if you break down everything that we've
said there's nothing that isn't common
sense in there but unfortunately common
sense isn't common practice no it's not
it's um I don't know why I don't know
why people get flustered I guess I want
to say especially face to face but also
online people have a tendency to not put
themselves across in the best way and
the remembered self from the situation
that oh I could have said that or I
should have said this
it's it's not due to a lack of cognitive
ability it's not that they're not quick
enough face-to-face or online to be able
to get this information out there just
seems to be a good is it nervousness is
it is it a lack of experience or a lack
of preparedness to be truthful or
vulnerable online I'm not really too
sure no no if you have a common
stumbling blocks that people have that
fundamental to they're not eliciting the
best influence that they can well I
think you you you've hit on a couple
there certainly they get in their own
way is what I would I would say if
you've come into a room in your mind you
know for example in networking room and
your minds on other things you know the
three jobs that you should had on your
to-do list that didn't get done the fact
you've you know you don't feel a million
dollars you haven't a chance to do you
make up or but you know maybe you know
wearing what you wanted to wear you
nervous about how you're going to come
across because of the baggage you carry
around about how people portray you if
you come in with all of that baggage in
it will any of it
you're not making your best first
impression you really have to leave the
world at the door and when in any kind
of relationship lead the world of the
door and and just focus on the
conversation from conversations come
opportunities it's a lovely way to put
it so I think we've got through a really
nice model of how people can improve
their ability to influence going from
understanding their why understanding
their audience understanding the mediums
and the media's that they can contact
them through the credibility through
Association the face-to-face the online
approaches that people can use and
you've given us some really lovely
examples are there any other points that
you think people need to hear before we
round this conversation off so there's
only a couple of them that maybe quotes
which will just provoke a bit of thought
and this could cause you know ultimately
actually you've summarized building
personal brand etc and actually I think
the kind of key messages if I was to
summarize they come
so we just had quizzes first of all we
we discussed the world is changing so
become that student of change
second of all we talked about becoming a
student of people so that's
understanding them and stand their
context their their communication
preferences their personality traits be
their student of people and that
includes being a student of yourself we
talked about listening as one of the
most effective tools when it comes to
influencing because it gives you context
but it also makes you liked then
connecting on a human level it's not all
about business you know give a bit of
yourself that's what people hearts and
minds and what people connecting
demonstrate your values tell your
stories I think that's I think that's
enough for anybody listening to this to
be able to do something meaning if you
stick to those you won't go too far
wrong right I can't I can't see how you
can but you know all of this there's a
number of quotes but the key to
successful leadership today is influence
not authoritative lancha that's one
that's on my website your circle of
influence dictates your path example is
not the main thing when it comes to
influencing others it's the only thing
you know all of these all of these are
hopefully things that anybody listening
to this will just understand that
whatever their objectives in life a
happier marriage a better relationship
with their kids stronger friendships
more cordial working environments with
colleagues more clients when it comes to
sales and marketing it's all about
influencing and the better they are at
these things the more effective they'll
be in all of those areas of their life
we are hugely important creatures you
know they've even done research where
they've had people to people in fMRI
scans one listening one talking they
couldn't see each other you know and in
an instant their brainwaves start to
synchronize you know to the point where
it's almost predictive from the listener
and that's how empathetic we are we want
to connect with others so just use that
you use all of those things to build
connection and be hume and remember what
i said only one in an age of AI and
Automation and roburt ization it's
important to stay human fantastic I've
absolutely loved today Warren I'm glad
it's been a it's been a long time coming
for me to get you on I'm really really
glad that I have done
so obviously the link to influence the
book will be in the show notes are the
my superstar are there any other
resources either yours or anyone elses
books or online blogs or where do you go
or where would you advise people who
want to further their knowledge into
this field why where should they look
well of course the modern wisdom podcast
is a good starting point for anybody
listening and and like everything else
it's important to share it so you get
the audience you deserve so right the
same is true for the book if you like
the book if anybody reads it and likes
it give us a shout out I'd love to hear
what one nuggets you took from on social
media and found that's how we connected
Chris exactly it's it's lovely when it
happened so if people do really on my
website there's a strategy guide which
is basically a PDF you see at the end of
every chapter in the book I ask a couple
of questions and to help people
contextualize what I've just said and
relate it to their own circumstances
well I'm they fill in the what filled
mine in mine is yeah superb superb well
do you know why that's music to my ears
because you know what I said to you
earlier on about ego versus effecting
change or inspiring change in others
when people actually write something
down that builds intention it means that
they're going to go and implement
something if they implement something
they're only going to have some sort of
positive effect that comes off the back
of it so I love the messages I get on
social media from people are saying
right this particular point has resulted
in this you know improve relationship
here we couldn't agree more I've just
I've just finished a podcast with dr.
you and Lawson and during that we
discussed gratitude journaling and
exactly the same thing there it's
writing down in intention it's one of
the reasons that I love the podcasting
platform because it forces me under
duress of a very very skeptical audience
sometimes to crystallize my thoughts
into a way that
has to be both truthful and that makes
sense a lot of the time when it's just
thought floating around in your mind
they they're these unhewn sort of
globules of idea and then as soon as you
have to verbalize it or write it down it
takes form in a very very different way
and I think that you can start to you
can start to be very rigorous assessing
your own stance on things that you might
have previously taken for granted or not
really understood and then when you when
you do get to writing things down so I I
couldn't agree more
so we've got influence we've got the
partner worksheet that you can download
on your website which will also be in
the show notes is there anything else
that people should be reading so in
terms of other books is that there's a
load out there and I'm a fan of Daniel
priestly and go and have a look at some
of his work entrepreneur evolution it's
a good one
have a look at charlie knees follow up
book two to psychology persuasion which
is called pre suasion preservation seems
pretty heavily touted at the moment it's
one that I haven't read but it's a if
you if you'd given it your ID said to
myself if you gave it your seal of
approval during this podcast that I
would go and get it so I think that's
just locked in my next order bill credit
usage I think oh there you go that's
that's a good use for EM Charlie and his
come comes from a very strong academic
background and with this with his work
but but now it's a good book and a lot
of the books I've really valued over the
years
unnecessarily sort of mainstream now I
loved one called richest man in Babylon
which is which is which is a story
around actually what what building a
business or what building wealth
actually actually looks like that's told
in an old tongue kind of story very good
you know bearing in mind the biggest
thing that we talked about today was
some at the beginning we surround change
go and go and read who moved my cheese
you know a simple book that can be read
to
an hour but just tells this tells the
story of mice and men and illustrates
why it's actually important to be
constantly moving and not wedded to your
current situation your current
circumstances everything's changing
around you you need to change with it so
there are a couple of books I absolutely
recommend fantastic warren where can the
listeners find you online at warren Cass
or Warren Cass calm fantastic well it's
been an absolute pleasure I'm I'm very
very glad that we got to delve into the
world of influence the the book is
currently about to but a quarter of the
way through I think my third read
through now and it's it's definitely
such an applicable subject field that as
you say the applications of it go from
professional to personal to absolutely
everything and I think that being a
student of people as you've said is um
is something that we all probably can
endeavor to to try and do a little bit
more and will reap some benefits from as
we do we're thrilled you've got so much
Roma Chris and I really appreciate the
invitation to come and speak on the
podcast and I look forward to the said
look forward to the up and coming next
episode the gratitude journal now it
sounds and sounds fascinating
thank you very much Warren thank you for
you time take care buddy thanks
[Music]